[Music]
my name is Maria and I'm a technical
program manager here at Google and with
me is Krishna who does product
management we both work on the developer
platform called actions on Google and in
this session we'll discuss how you can
create actions for your existing Android
apps and then we'll talk about how you
can leverage those actions to build
deeper integrations with the Google
assistant so that you can reach more
users on your devices great everybody is
you're bright and energetic in the
morning all right let's have a quick
show of hands first how many of you
attended the app action session on
Tuesday all right I see a few hands so
today you're going to talk a little bit
about how you can enable actions on your
Android apps and how you can make them
surface across various touch points in
the Android platform if that sounds
interesting we had this very detailed
session two days ago which had a lot of
code samples etc so definitely I request
you to take a look at those code samples
at that video and we also have an office
hours immediately after that you can so
you can come and ask us for questions so
we're going to provide a quick recap on
app actions and Android apps then you're
going to talk a little bit about how you
as Android developers can use the same
development mechanism that you use for
app actions to basically create
conversational actions to take your
services to the plethora of new smart
devices coming out okay so that's the
agenda for today but let's start with
what our actions our devices are our
portal to the world we do everything
with them we watch videos we consume
content we navigate the world using our
devices and there are two primary
critical user needs for how people use
devices one is they actually consume
content and that includes everything
from listening to music to watching
videos to giving your best recipes etc
the other is we use our devices to get
things done the world has changed right
like you're no more running back to your
desktop to find maps or to book a piece
or to book a ticket or to purchase
something online you use your device
it's our single portal to the world hub
over there are something like 2 million
Android apps out there and this probably
like several hundred millions of
websites that's awesome
that gives the users enormous choice and
possibilities but there can also be a
little bit overwhelming just try
thinking immediately of like which app
do I immediately use to find the best
fish taco in San Diego right there's
just a lot of apps out there and for you
as a developer it's even more
problematic because it causes problems
of discovery and reengagement
so there was a statistic in Android
Authority in March 2016 that 77% of
users don't use the app within three
days of installation that's man that's
crazy and that number goes up to 90%
within a month so in this very crowded
space it's hard to get this free
engagement and you're developing all
these cool new features but even though
the user might have installed your app
they just don't know what's going on
they don't know what are the new
capabilities of the app so we are
providing a sneak peek on what we call
as app actions Dave Burke mentioned this
in the consumer keynote today or a
couple of days ago and app actions is a
way for you as Android developers to
surface the capabilities of your app and
bring that up so that Google can surface
your capabilities your actions and your
content across many different
touchpoints across the android platform
as the Android platform evolves to an AI
first world we are moving from just
predicting the next app to predicting
the next action that the user might take
and we will surface the capabilities of
your app at just the right moment either
based on the user context the user
routine or based on things like the user
query so this gives you instant increase
in both reach and reengagement but how
does this all work how does this show up
in in the in the Android platform let's
start with Google assistance which
everybody is interested in
you can with app actions you can
basically get your Android apps to have
a basic integration and shortcut with a
Google assistant for tasks based queries
so in this particular scenario the user
has asked something like manage my
budget and that immediately brings up
the mint app straight to the budget page
how is this done it is because the main
app in this example has registered for
an intent of budget management in this
file called as actions dot XML and we'll
go through a lot more in detail of how
exactly you register for intense this
also works for content-based queries so
I have asked what is Lady Gaga's real
name and believe it or not I really
didn't know till now Stephanie okay we
now try to understand and predict what
is the next follow-on action that the
user might do if I'm basically find it
searching for Lady Gaga I think it's a
natural conclusion that I might want to
listen to her latest album or watch a
video or buy tickets for our concerts so
we try to predict the next action and
show that as suggestion chips down the
bed down in the bottom clicking on any
of those suggestion chips immediately
opens the appropriate Android app
straight to the Lady Gaga page just
think about what a good like how many
steps you're still saving here
you're not remedying through your app
bra to find out the app then you're not
typing Lady Gaga there again and then
you're not trying to find out what it
all of this happens magically so that it
just surfaces up across the Android
platform we are also exploring how we
can actually serve face apps that you
use a lot directly in Google search so I
use Fandango to book tickets so if I
type a movie like Avengers it shows me
various suggestions tips for Fandango
right at the bottom so clicking on any
of those suggestion chips will basically
take me directly into Fandango where I
can immediately purchase a ticket as
Android a walls last year in Android oh
we brought up this concept of predicting
the neck
app that you might use there is a top
the top column that you top row that you
see there this actually had a 60%
prediction accuracy rate and was wildly
successful now what you're doing is
actually moving from predicting the next
app to predicting the next action that
you might do so in this this blue
highlighted column there you see
basically two suggestions and these are
two suggestions that happen in my phone
at around 5:00 to 5:30 in the evening
and this is based on the frequency of
usage for various tasks and actions I do
so here's my routine at five o'clock I
called my spouse Mona right and then I
argue with her has to who has to pick up
the kids I inevitably lose that argument
and then I never get to my kids school
to pick up the kids so those two
suggestions those two actions happen
very often and therefore it is shown up
as suggestions now these suggestions are
contextual and routine based so for
example if you live in San Francisco and
you use the transit app at the transit
station when you approach the transit
station it knows that particular context
and it will automatically show a
suggestion for the transit app and those
are the types of predictions that we can
do based on many different inputs of
context and routines we are also
directly working with app actions and
things like smart select so in an email
or in the browser if I choose a piece of
text what happens is that smart text
smart text as our selection uses machine
learning to predict the full entity so
if I click on floor in this particular
example it basically selects the whole
floor and water which is a restaurant
and shows me the action for reserving a
table using open table now when I click
on open table it immediately takes me to
the open tables floor and water page
where basically I can book the table
immediately so these are all ways in
which app actions surface across many
different places for
apps that you have installed on your
device which thus leads to more
reengagement because we understand the
type of capabilities that your apps have
and continue to expand upon but what
about apps which are not installed app
actions also shows up on the Play Store
page in the Play Store page if I type
and query Lady Gaga you know slightly
gets it shows me various actions that
have apps how both for apps that are
installed on my device and apps which
are not installed this allows for great
discovery because you actually
understand the capabilities of the apps
that can actually directly act upon the
query that you have provided in this
case of Lady Gaga you get like a bunch
of suggestions for apps which can do
everything from playing music to show
lyrics and if that particular show
lyrics app is not installed when I click
on it it will basically give me the
option to install that app and then it
will directly take me to the deep link
for Lady Gaga no app actions is very
interesting this is part of the larger
actions on google framework so we have
created a common development mechanism
which includes built-in intents which is
how you actually show the capabilities
of your app that is the API to show the
capabilities of your app and that same
built int intent mechanism can be used
for app actions conversational actions
vertical programs and so on and so forth
you have created a foundation layer that
enables you to create actions across
multiple platforms operating systems and
surfaces will go a lot more into that
great so those were some really cool
examples of how the actions of your
Android app can be featured in
suggestions across the Android surfaces
now let's take a look at some of the
steps of creating app actions to achieve
just that so first using tools you're
all familiar with for building and
publishing Android apps namely the
Android studio and the Play Developer
console you'll create an actions XML
file and this is the central place for
all of the actions that your Android app
can't support there are two key pieces
of information that you'll need to
provide for each action and that is the
intent and the fulfillment which
describes the what and the how of your
actions so let's dive deeper into some
of these concepts and we'll start with
built-in intents which is how you
indicate what your action does my team
at Google has built and published a
catalogue of built-in intense and as
Krishna mentioned this is one of the
core foundational elements of app
actions if you think about the way users
ask for information there's a myriad of
linguistic variations that they can use
to construct their query so for example
they can say calming activities or they
can say breathing exercises to relax
about a presentation or they can ask for
10-minute meditation techniques all of
these queries they indicate that the
user would like to de-stress or they'd
like to calm down
so we've designed built-in intense in
such a way that they abstract away all
of the natural linguistic variations and
we pass on only the relevant information
to your application from the users query
using parameters and so to give Google a
deep understanding of what your Android
app can do what you need to do is
register for the relevant built-in
intents that are relevant to your app
and this will help Google show the right
actions to users at the right time here
are some of the intents that we're
working on now and the ones that have a
star next to them are available for
developers to try out today in preview
and throughout the remainder of the year
we'll be continuously extending this
catalog to cover as many of you use
cases as we can and if you have an
android app where we're not covering the
use case currently please do give us
feedback we take it very seriously and
we'll show you how to do that at the end
of this talk now let's talk about
fulfillment which describes how a user
would invoke a specific action within
your app so when users express an action
that they'd like to accomplish a task or
an intent that they have you can help
them fulfill that action by specifying
deep links into your
Android apps so in your actions XML you
can define the mapping between the
built-in intents and the deep link URL
and this will enable Google to show the
right content to your users from your
Android app and deep link them directly
into the experience that they seek in
that specific moment so we have two
models for fulfillment in the first
model which is the URL template model we
construct the deep link URL based on the
user's query parameters and your actions
XML will tell us how to map the
parameters from the built in intent to
the URL parameters and this model is
ideal for action centric apps with deep
link api's and in the content driven
model we discover the the fulfillment
URL through your web content or the
structured data that you give us and
then based on the user's query we find
the relevant content and then use your
actions XML to connect the content to
the appropriate intent so let's see an
example of how this would work and we'll
use the Coursera Android app and we'll
show you how they registered for the
action of take course and the reason
that they want to do this is so that
when a user comes to the Android and
they want to they want to know
information about courses or education
we can ensure that the Coursera app is
shown to them as a suggestion and for
this demo we'll also show you how the
suggestion will show up on the Google
assistant so for the built in intent we
created one and it's called take course
and it takes a single parameter of the
type course and this is the parameter
that if you were to implement to
register for this particular intent you
would need to handle it from the user's
query and so for example the user might
say take a machine learning course with
Coursera and the assistant will know
that machine learning is of type course
name or if they ask for fine data
science courses on Coursera the
assistant will match the data science
parameter to the correct type of course
that named it about because that's what
the course is about now you might wonder
how to
you will exactly know this particular
mapping so in cceres case each course
page is annotated with schema.org markup
and there's a page called machine
learning and it is associated with a
specific URL so this is an example of
the content-based fulfillment that we
talked about a couple of slides back and
so to bring these two things together we
have our actions XML and we tie these
two things together in a really simple
way so first you register for the built
in intent of take cores and then we take
the course parameter and map it to the
main web page URL for Coursera for
learning and that's it it is that simple
so let's now see how this app action
will show up on my pixel device in the
assistant so let's go to the assistant
and we'll ask it about machine learning
machine learning
great so what we see here is a basic
part about machine learning from the
assistant but now below in the
suggestions we see the take force action
that we just created and we know that
it's from Coursera because of the apps
icon now let's see what happens when I
tap into it awesome so it takes me to
the Coursera app directly into the
machine learning course page that I just
asked about and from here I can do
things like enroll and I can also
explore the rest of my app so as the
user that was really impressing about
how quick and simple that experience was
for me in just two taps I was able to
enroll for my course right away and for
courser it was also fairly simple right
just by creating a single actions XML
file
Coursera can now get users to discover
and re-engage with their Android app
across multiple touch points on the
Android device but there's one caveat
here this will only work on Android
devices today we know that users are
beginning to increasingly to turn to new
device types to accomplish their daily
tasks and so in this next part we'll
talk about how you can go beyond the
Android and how you can reach these
users that are using these new devices
that don't run the Android thanks Maria
that was very cool just a single file
actions or ex-mo and you can get your
actions surfacing up in various touch
points across the operating system works
great for Android devices and you can
bring up the content and capabilities of
your app but what about all these other
devices which are coming up in the
market you cannot go to an electronic
store without smart without saying smart
speakers Smart TVs smart displays smart
whatever right and all of these are
Google assistant enabled but these are
not Android devices or it is many of
them are not Android devices how do you
as a service provider bring your
services bring your functionality to all
these new devices and first of all as an
Android developer why should you even
care about
let's talk a little bit about that so
Google has been doing a bunch of user
research on how people interact get
information and get their tasks done
throughout the day and our associate
shown that the way people interact to
accomplish their tasks throughout the
day are very different and the type of
tasks that they do is also very
different for example in the morning
when you cooked a quickly cooking
breakfast and you're not rush to get out
you might quickly catch up on news find
the traffic find the better check your
calendar and then rush out and when
you're commuting you might might you
might be checking the news or listening
to music navigating and that's very
different from when you're at home in
the evening relaxing cooking dinner or
watching a TV with you're watching the
TV with your family and you want to find
out the latest buzz Netflix show right
the types of devices you use is
different the types of information that
you want to get is very different in the
context that you're in you're relaxing
on the couch or you're driving those
contexts are also very different and
increasingly users are starting to use
many different types of devices when
you're cooking breakfast when your hands
are tied when your hands are greasy you
don't necessarily want to pull out your
phone you're brand new spanking new
costly form and when you're commuting
you might want to get some information
on the latest score what is your base
how does your deal look like but your
hands are busy or at least you shouldn't
be using your Android phone in those
contexts when you are going for a jog
you might want to check your calories or
you want to might want to check the
steps that you're done but again you may
not necessarily be carrying out your
phone and finally when you're in front
of the TV and want to get the latest
Netflix show the phone may not be
necessarily the best context users are
increasingly becoming more sophisticated
on how they interact with devices and
they expect that their devices will
provide the right information to them as
well as help them accomplish their tasks
in the most hassle-free and the most
natural way possible they don't want to
contort themselves into trying to use a
device where it's not
right for that particular context and
Google assistant has been spending a lot
of time thinking of these critical user
journeys and being there for the user in
all of these contexts Google assistant
enables you to interact with users at
completely new ways using a combination
of voice rich UI cards UI and many sort
of these intermodal behaviors it enables
you to create fundamentally new
experiences thus reaching and engaging
your users in a different way for these
different contexts and the Google
assistant is now on across 500 million
plus devices everything from phones to
smart speakers to smart TVs to smart
displays than headphones so that you can
reach your user in the right context in
the right place that where they are so
the answer that increase your breadth of
adoption of your services across all of
these different contexts now making a
conversational response interaction
seems complex but we have built a
cutting-edge technology stack to take
away a lot of that complexity we have
built all this natural language
processing individual voice recognition
machine learning algorithms for
inflection etc different voice types and
using course Google's core assets in the
knowledge graph identity payments and
put together a technology stack so that
we can make it easier for us developers
can you imagine building all of this
infrastructure by yourself for every
single app it's just not feasible so we
have built this technology stack and we
invite you to build upon on top of our
technology stack and focused on building
compelling new experiences for your
users
conversational actions are again part of
the larger Google framework you will use
the same intense that Maria talked about
the built in intents that Maria talked
about that you use for app actions also
for conversational actions and during
the rest of this session we will see
some of the foundational elements that
enable your Android apps and services to
work more see
see with your conversational actions but
you're probably thinking now oh man
there's Google you're asking me to
rebuild my whole app for voice come on
okay so I'm not asking you to rebuild or
replicate your whole app I'm I want to
bring this concept of a companion
conversational action a companion action
is basically providing a snippet of
information or helping the user complete
a specific task that the user might use
of your service in their different
context the best way to think about this
is through an example let us take the
case of gold alert go alert is a pretty
popular soccer app which has rich
information on beams in Europe league
tables points all of that good stuff
fantastic I use it every day during the
World Cup all right so what happens when
I go to a completely different context
I'm driving to work and I just want to
catch up with the latest score as to
what happened yesterday keep in mind an
Android app such as this which is not
part of messaging or media will not show
full screen on Android auto - so how do
you actually get this information to the
user and extend that reached to a new
context so what good alert has done is
they found that piece of their service
such as check the latest score which
makes most sense for the user in a
completely different context and they
have created a simple conversational
action which provides the response for
what are the results of the Premier
League or what of what happened to the
match yesterday or what are the scores
so we created a rich conversational + dy
response which can be used across all
assistant devices let's take another
example todoist todoist as everybody
knows is a popular to-do app it's a rich
to-do app at more than 10 million
downloads it has all sorts of detailed
task information different ways you can
manipulate it etc great what will you do
when you're cooking breakfast and you
just want to find what is what task to
help you today here again to do is test
thought through the critical user
journeys that their use
how and figured out that what tasks do I
have do today is is a service which goes
across multiple context across multiple
devices so they've created a
conversational action to provide a
single easy response to what do I have
do today so the as far as a developer
journey with actions goes for building
these conversational actions for app
actions you're familiar with this you're
created in android apk you're going to
add an action start XML file using
Android studio you will test it out in
Android studio and you will publish it
using the standard Play control
mechanisms for publishing your Android
app let's take that for conversational
for conversational you're going to again
use the same built-in intent mechanism
to build conversational actions you will
build simple conversational actions
using dialogue flow which is a which is
a tool provided by actions and Google
and you'll go to the actions on Google's
actions console to manage publish your
your conversational agent and
conversational action let us see how all
of this works together from an
high-level architecture perspective if
I'm creating an app and let's say this
is Krishna's to-do app it's a task-based
app what I'm going to do is I'm going to
put up a web server node.js or Apache or
whatever connect it to a database where
all of my users to do tasks are stored
then I'm going to create an Android app
which basically talks to the web server
to get that users information provided
back to my app which will render it
based on the UI design of my app the
same concept works for our friends down
the street and it also works for ever
based interface to your app when you
then go to conversational agents what
you're going to do is you're going to
create a conversational agent which
basically will talk to your web server
using the same API same infrastructure
that you're provided what happens is for
a query of
what tasks do I have today the assistant
will take care of all of the natural
language processing query understanding
it understands what the query is and
then invokes your agent your agent will
then basically you understand that query
and now your agent has to actually do a
fulfillment for that query so to do the
fulfillment what you're going to do is
you're going to use a web hook which
will connect to the web server on your
back-end and then provide the response
back to the user the key point here is
that you as a developer are using the
exact same infrastructure API identity
mechanisms that you're already used for
your apps to also provide a
conversational response for all of
assistent enabled devices now let's talk
a little bit more about this
foundational layer maria explained a
little bit about built-in intents but we
also provide a certain set of
foundational elements which basically
lets you create easy seamless
interaction between your Android apps
and your conversational agents let's
again go back to our to-do list or to-do
app and let's think a little bit about
account linking you probably as an
Android developer especially if you have
some sort of service back-end have some
form of an account management system
todoist uses various identity mechanism
including Google as an identity and as a
user when I start using today based on
Android I can create my identity using
Google or through some other identity
mechanism when you go to the assistant
and when you set up to do this for the
first time on your assistant you will
have to link your todoist
identity to the assistant once you do
the linking you can use your
conversational response across any
assistant enabled device without having
to login into todoist again the key
point here is that in in actions console
you can link your
so that things work seamlessly and with
one step of a cone clinking for the user
the user can use to-do lists across any
assistant enabled device that is account
linking let us talk a little bit about
Play entitlements and seamless digital
subscriptions the interesting thing is
that both the assistant and Android uses
as Google Play for inventory and order
management and entitlements management
because of the fact that both of them
use the same Google Play infrastructure
entitlements subscriptions in-app
purchases works seamlessly across both
assistant and Android let us take the
case of Economist espresso economists is
a great magazine and they have an app
called as Economist espresso which has a
subscription feature to get their
premium articles I went and logged in
into my Android app and paid the
subscription in Android now when I go to
the assistant and use economist espresso
I immediately get access to all of their
premium content because the assistant
also knows that I have a premium
subscription to Economist espresso and
hence I'm availa am eligible for all of
the premium content and this works
Reverse also you can you can purchase
subscriptions in the assistant and it
will work on your Android app also and
if this way this works again can be done
in the actions console the assistant
first will check whether you have access
to these premium subscriptions you can
then purchase content using the same
inventory and order management system
and then your your premium subscriptions
work across the assistant and is
mentioned also across Android so in all
of these scenarios about companion
conversational actions these these
developers what he did is they thought
of this very specific use case and built
a conversational action so here are my
principles for building a companion
conversational action you're not just an
app provider you are a service provider
and as a service pro I
you want to take your service your
functionality to many new contexts so
think beyond the app and think of the
service that you're providing also what
is the critical user journey for your
service like how do people actually
interact with your service in what
context in what device and can you think
of new contexts and devices in which
your service actually makes sense to the
user and also you're going to expand the
reach of your your service quite a bit
but please do not think of just
replicating your whole app for voice you
need to think of the specific service
that makes sense for the user so my
challenge to you is what are the
compelling new experiences that you can
create by integrating with a Google
assistant please join these number of
providers who already created an Android
app but I've also expanded their reach
to a number of Google enabled devices by
building a conversational agent thanks
Sam so that was a really high-level
overview for how you can think about
companion actions to your Android app
how to really think about the experience
that you can provide your users for
those times in their life when their
Android device just might not be handy
so there's two such times that come to
my mind right away and first of first of
which is while I'm driving and my full
attention used to be on the road and my
Android device is usually in my pocket
and then the second is while I'm
clicking and my hands are usually either
busier or they're dirty and it's really
inconvenient to have to keep going back
and forth between washing my hands
unlocking my phone reading the recipe
making my food washing my hands
unlocking my phone you get the idea
right this is a normal cooking process
so I have two devices to help me in
these situations I have the assistant in
my car and I have the smart display at
home so I'd like to go back to the
Coursera example that we introduced
earlier and I'd like to show you how we
help them take their app beyond Android
so that it could accompany me throughout
my day but the situations that I just
described so we all know machine
learning is a pretty hot topic right now
and so as we saw earlier I did register
for it on Coursera and I like to go
through my courses after work so I like
to listen to the course podcasts while
I'm driving in my car and then when I
get home I like to continue watching the
video for the course that I started to
listen to in the car now neither my car
nor my smart device at home
Ronni Android right both of these
devices they only work with the Google
assistant and so let's see how we helped
build the Coursera companion app that
works on the Google assistant here's the
actions Excel that we showed you earlier
where they registered for the take
course built in intent
and now after their apk was approved and
published in the Play Developer console
there now appeared an option there to
enhance actions with actions on Google
and clicking their lands us in the
actions console project claiming page
now this console is a really focused way
to develop and manage your companion
action for the Google assistant and
we're very excited because this week we
announced a major redesign of this
console and it basically helps you do
three main things it first allows you to
configure set up the metadata and the
directory listing information for your
companion app and then it allows you to
manage the development the testing and
the deployment process in a very
fine-grained way and then once your
action is published it gives you
analytics so that you can track how your
action is doing out there with real
users in the real world now there's a
lot of magic that happens here during
this project claiming stage for example
we automatically import most of the
information that you provided in the
actions XML to make it easier for you to
develop your companion app now let's see
what the actions console looks like for
Coursera after they've gone through the
claiming process
so this is the actions console and we
can see that it's already set up with
the Coursera demo apps let's click into
this action section and we see here the
take course built in intent that we had
an Android that's automatically imported
from actions XML we went through that
claiming process and when we click in
we'll hopefully see some magical
information show up here there we go so
we see all of the triggering we see all
of the important information that you
would want to know about this action so
for example the triggering phrases up
there these are sample invocations that
users can use to invoke this particular
action and we've see the parameters as
well as the fulfillment information that
you provided us in your actions XML and
that was automatically imported into
here now that we have this basic wiring
set up what we can do is we can create a
rich response using dialogue flow to
cover those two cases that I described I
wanted to have earlier for Coursera so
to listen to my course podcasts while
I'm driving and then to continue
watching my video when I get at home and
to do that you would just add the
fulfillment of conversational type here
and this will land us in dialogue flow
where you can specify the details about
the fulfillment now because we're a bit
short on time today I won't show you how
you can build fulfillment from scratch
but there are a few key components that
I'd like to walk you through so that you
can see how to do this for yourself so
this is the dialogue flow tool and this
is the JavaScript for our fulfillment
code we see here that we first used the
take course built in intent that we walk
through earlier and then we reference
the course parameter to understand what
is the name of the course that is coming
in from the users query we also created
a function that calls the back end
Coursera service to get the details from
the course that the user is asking about
and then when we get the response what
we can do is
Parsa and for this particular example
we'll just create a simple card that
shows us all of the course information
and then we use our media response API
to return the audio or the video of the
course based on what device I'm running
on now one really one really amazing
thing about dialog flow is that it's
it's simply integrated with the actions
console it has a really deep integration
with that console and so this provides a
really nice development environment
where you can do things like test how
this would work on the Google assistant
directly from this UI just by simply
clicking in this section so let's see
how this a basic card that I just showed
you we created would look like in the
simulator so this is the simulator and
we also have a test on device option so
you can test during your process to see
how it would work on the device but for
now let's see how this would work when
we invoke our Coursera demo app so we'll
say ask Coursera demo to start my
machine learning course
sure here's the test version of Coursera
demo here's more information about
machine learning do you want to start
the course great so what we see here is
the card that we created right so all of
those description information down here
the title of the card this image the
suggestion chips down there they were
all specified in the fulfillment code
that I showed you in dialogue flow so
now let's say yes to start the course
podcast
sure here's your course on machine
learning oh great
so this allows me to listen to the
course podcasts while I'm driving now
let's imagine that I started doing that
in my car and then when I get home I
want to continue watching my video on
the smart display device so let's try it
here and hopefully it works
okay Google continue my course sorry I
don't know how to help with that yet
let's try that I'm trying to learn ok
Google continue my course sorry
go try ok Google continue my course okay
let's get Coursera
welcome to Coursera you want to continue
your machine learning course yes sure
here is your course both of you also see
what the overall process of I thank you
[Applause]
thank you demo gods all right so let me
jump in on a quick recap of what we just
did we showed you how to create actions
XML and how to use built-in intents to
enable actions in your android app and
then we showed you how by doing so your
app can now be discovered across the
menu surfaces on Android
now we briefly glossed over these two
but we had our colleagues give a whole
talk on how to build a pack shion's two
days ago and if you missed it don't
worry please do go ahead and watch the
video on YouTube now in the main
of the demo we walked through how to
clean your actions in Google project so
that you can enable your actions to work
on new devices and finally we showed you
how to build and test a simple companion
app that works great with audio and
video on a smart display now we
certainly think this is very cool we're
very excited and we try to make it
really easy for you so that a companion
app like this is just another interface
to your existing service building
experiences that work on devices which
don't run Android is not about bringing
up completely new infrastructure from
scratch it's more about just extending
your apps to be more action centric and
more focused on connecting with your
users throughout their day wherever
there are whether at home or there on
the go so with that let me oh sorry with
that let me invite you to visit our web
page at actions that google.com to learn
more about the concepts and the tools
that we covered today and we want to
hear from you so please do sign up at G
d'arco slash apps Ock app actions so
that you can give us feedback on our
built in intent catalog and also by
sending up you'll get notified when app
actions become available but most
importantly what we encourage you today
is start thinking about the experience
you can provide your users for those
times in their life when their Android
device just might be impractical or just
inconvenient to use in that moment take
the next step today and build companion
actions on devices that work for the
Google assistant we want to thank you
for joining us and if you have any
questions please come by our office
hours in the sandbox area please enjoy
the rest of your time at i/o
[Music]